[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with my
good friend Ramsey personality Jay de
warshaw and we're answering your
questions life money relationships
career anything and everything give us a
call the first up in Gainesville Florida
we have camon on the line hey Cameron
welcome to the show Howdy thank you um
so my question is my parents just sold
their house in Texas and they got a
considerable amount of money for it um
and they're currently in the process of
um basically planning for their future
and I recently also purchased a house in
Gainesville Florida which is part
investment property I'm I'm living there
at the same time it's kind of renting
out rooms in addition to it um and my
father brought up to me hey with all
this extra money that we now have you
know would you like us to pay off your
house and then that way you'll just pay
us back instead of paying back the bank
and I've kind of heard before you know
Dave talk about it's not good to take
money from family members and I kind of
just wanted to hear y'all's perspective
on it the pros and the cons
here yeah I mean I think if you look at
the pro side sometimes families in the
situation they do it with less interest
and all this stuff but I think honestly
Cameron there's just more
cons in this because I think the math
side sometimes can play into people and
they're like oh well I don't have to
they're not going to charge me Interest
or like whatever the deal is that's a
better deal than the bank but here's the
truth I'm like it's a house number one
you're not talking about like we're
going to pay off a $5,000 car it's your
house and so for now and in the next
next foreseeable 5 10
years you're going to be having
Christmases and family dinners and
you're going to want Cameron to go on a
great trip and they may be thinking wow
why is he going on a trip he needs to be
paying us back I mean like you know like
it starts to like it starts to play into
the relationship in a pretty deep way
where your parents ends up being your
bank and again all good intentions like
I I hear that cuz I think a lot of
parents go into this and and and their
heart in it is so good but the way it
plays out Cameron like it just ends up
getting Messier yeah I'm just thinking
about okay so if you're in the in the
baby step where you're paying off your
house early right you might commit to
hey we're going to make an extra
mortgage payment every month right but
then something might come up in your
house where you go you know what we're
not going to make a full extra mortgage
payment we're going to do this or that
and you kind of have the the freedom to
choose what you're going to do but when
your parents are the bank and if they
get used to you paying on a certain
schedule a certain amount and then you
and your wife decide there's another
priority right now we're not going to do
as much like Rachel said I just feel
like there's this weird feeling of oh
they stopped paying 6,000 a month and
now they're only paying 4,000 I wonder
what that's about like I just feel like
there's so much there and then and I
mean I'm I'm not saying anything
negative but there are the negative side
of things that we have to think about
which is something with your parent
situation changes and suddenly they need
more money or something with your
situation changes and suddenly you don't
have as much money you can't afford the
house anymore for some reason and then
they looking for yeah yeah there's a lot
I I wouldn't do it okay because let me
one little sorry let me ask you one
followup real quick because you said an
something about an investment property
this isn't their house is it it's yours
no it's not this is my own personal
house it's just that it it's more than
what I currently need and so I have um
it was it being in Gainesville near the
local college so I have um you know
young adults that live in the additional
rooms gotcha gotcha how much just for
wondering how much was it that they were
going to pay off on your a little over
100,000 yeah and I'm currently putting
an additional about $3,500 per month
towards it and that's actually what my
second question was going to be in
regards to I have about
$25,000 liquid right now on top of my
emergency fund and I wonder is it worth
it to just throw all of that in on the
mortgage right now or should I kind of
save that and maybe you know wait for a
better opportunity
look if you're on baby step six
absolutely the case um if you're not you
know in this case it sounds like you are
you you don't have any other debt I'm
sure you're investing 15% of your income
um you know obviously you already have a
home are you savings for kids college
like that kind of thing if you know
you're checking off all those boxes then
or the applicable boxes then yes I would
do that yeah and if you know you know
that there may be a you know you have to
replace a car soon or um you know you
use that money for something else if
there's something you want to redo in
the house I don't know if there's other
expenses you know are coming you could
leave some of that aside just as a
buffer you know savings fund to be able
to pull from if you need if you need
that extra cash um especially with
winers yeah yeah exactly but I would put
a big I would put a big chunk of that
yeah towards towards the mortgage to get
it paid off faster so thanks Cameron
thanks for the call you know Jade I feel
like the family Dynamic with loaning
money it is and it's one and what's
what's always kind of hard for me in
this seat I know there's families out
there that are like this can work it can
work and then there's like the disaster
families the disaster families are kind
of easy to be like my mom's saying I
have to you know you could paint a
picture pretty quickly to be like yeah I
probably wouldn't do that I wouldn't do
that deal and then there's some families
where it's like you know the the parents
are healthy it's a good situation all of
it but still even with that even with
that it just changes
the relationship I would think and I
don't think it it would even take
anything like truly negative happening I
really think it's just the the
difference of we were used to this
payment and it seems like you're you've
been paying less and them just wanting
to ask the question why even if they
don't which they have the right to
because they're technically the bank
right in that scenario and even if they
never do like even if even if as the
child or like the grown child you never
they never come to you and say hey we
were wondering what happened just them
even wondering it has the ability affect
the way they're viewing you like Hey
we're all going Black Friday shopping
and they see you you know spending money
they might in their own head be like
interesting she spent $1,000 here but
she didn't like and you just don't want
people thinking of you through that lens
at all times that's right that's right
it's just the human quality of it and
especially the parent to the child
relationship it just again sometimes
well intentioned yeah and all of it but
we've seen it so often so often go
sideways and people even talk like with
friends and everything and I'm like it
just just keep it all separate it's like
I don't want to I mean think about how
just as people think about how we are if
we've ever heard a friend or family
member say oh I'm I'm saving up for this
or I'm doing this or I'm doing that and
then we after they've said that we view
what they're doing with their money so
if they say oh we're saving up for you
know down payment on a house then it
makes sense when they say oh we're not
going to go out to dinner we're not you
you start filtering it through what they
said they're going to do right right and
so if that changes you're like Oh I
thought that said they were saving for a
house like you just you can't help it
and I just wouldn't want my own parents
doing that which honestly borrowing
money in general not even just for a
house or a mortgage but anytime for a
car for a personal loan I mean anything
yeah so we always say if you have the
money you can give it as a gift and
again with the parent child relationship
there are some situations where it is a
gift and the parents can afford it the
child can can handle that gift and it's
a beautiful thing of changing a legacy
with something right like that 100 % can
work yes but then also on the other side
there's parents that enable
children and it can be dysfunctional too
so it's never about the money right it's
never about the money it's always about
the person who's handling it in that
specific situation so always give never
lend this is the Ramy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the ramsy show it is
full shopping week I feel like for all
of us the last two weeks and so we
actually have the Cyber Monday sale you
guys going all week long so all this
week we have extended our Cyber Monday
sale which means there's great gifts
meaningful gifts for your friends and
family as low is $7 we have every dollar
premium you can get a gift card for that
uh for just $49.99 Financial Peace
universities
$59.99 um things like the Junior's
Adventure storytime collection $14.99
the goal planner is for
$44.99 so lots of stuff lots of things
from Jade myself Dr John delone Ken
colan Dave
Ramsey what whatever it is about your f
about your finances your relationships
your career you can check that all out
at ramsy solutions.com store again our
week long Cyber Monday sale is all week
long which is a beautiful thing we love
a good sale love go to gift is that goal
planner I get that I get several of them
every year and give them out yes oh it's
beautiful they're they're so so great
all right up next we have uh
marcial from the woodlands in Texas hey
welcome to the show hi guys thanks for
taking my call such an honor being on
the phone with you guys absolutely
thanks for calling how can we help okay
so uh my wife and I been listening to
the ransy show for the last six months
so we already read the books and we are
working on the baby steps but our income
is regular she's starting a career as a
real estate agent I'm self employe I'm
an entrepreneur I have a business and uh
we we have some money saved up we just
have debt in cars we have two cars in
one we owe 15,000 the other one we ow
13,000 we're getting rid of the $133,000
one so we're just just going to tackle
the $15,000 one my question is since our
income is so regular is it a smart to
set aside instead of $1,000 just $5,000
and then throw the rest at the cars and
also I have a five a small $4,000
student loan um so that's the question
is it smart to set aside instead of
$1,000
$5,000 and then tackle with the rest of
the money the the debt and if we have a
good month then we we throw extra on the
debt or what do you guys think about
that yeah I W okay so with the IR
regular income there's two ways that you
could think of it there's two ways I
would think of it number one if you're
able to create a budget based on your
worst month like right you can look back
in your self-employed job and go okay
like what's what's my worst month been
over the course of the year and your
wife can look back and go okay what's my
worst month been and can start to budget
from there and then you know okay like
everything else is gravy if you can make
that work then I would just do the
normal thousand emergency fund as normal
now if you're like no we are really like
this thing is a crazy roller coaster and
the months that we don't do well like
nothing's happening what I would do is
there is something to be said for having
money that you are carrying over from
month to month I wouldn't view it as an
emergency fund so much as this is just
living expenses this yeah this is just
roll over from a previous month that I
keep there almost like a cushion for my
budget um and I think that's very normal
for people who are on irregular income
because there is such variance there um
the third part of this I I know I said
there was two things but there's three
things Rachel the third part of this is
if you are going through such low
valleys to such high peaks or if you
feel like there's a lot of low valleys
that might be an indicator that there
needs to be another source of regular
income coming in at least until you can
make this a little bit more steady more
stable yep got it got it no that that's
not the case because in a bad month uh
we average five to six grand a month
that's the worst month that's like a
really bad month and if that's the case
and again your expenses and everything
can handle that which I'm assuming so
then yes $1,000 is enough then that's
enough so uh but yeah we call them yeah
Peaks and valleys kind of with the
budget and I mean that's how Jade and I
both are on commission it's the way
we're structured and so some months it's
like oh yeah it's been a great month
some months it's like nope not much
activity happening and there it is but
that there's enough in there to make
sure that our bills are covered because
we don't want you to get behind on your
mortgage or not have money for food I
mean yeah we're that's that's common
sense so we want to be able to have
enough there but if it is then yes
Marcel I would throw the rest I would I
would go down to that thousand emergency
fund um and then I would for you you you
named off a couple of debts but I would
um can I would pay off that student loan
the 4,000 I'd get that out of the first
now what did you say about the $133,000
Carl you kind of glossed over that and
said but we're going to pay on the
15,000 yeah the that's the that's a card
that was it was a mistake it was a
desperation uh uh purchase because my
wife and I we filed for bankruptcy like
a year ago and then uh I lost my truck
and and I had to buy a car and I bought
a car at caran at a 24% interest rate
zero down because it I needed a car I
needed to move I didn't have $2,000 to
pay for a car car so we bought that car
and we are a little bit upside down in
it uh so we're just going to uh sell it
and pay the difference to get that so
yeah that's the plan for that car
perfect well that's great yeah that that
that sounds amazing and good for you
guys I mean coming out of
bankruptcy um out of that and then a
year later that you guys are like hey we
got to clean this stuff up because you
know that is one that is one part of
money that is so crucial and you talk
about this a lot Jade in your quick read
that you know money's not a math problem
is that you know so often we just try to
fix the math and we try to go after the
interest rat we try to go after this but
realizing which again uh martial I feel
like the light has come on for him and
his wife where he's like oh we're the
problem like we are so we're going to
have to do some things to change our
behavior when it comes to money because
that's that's really the crucial part of
winning that's right and I know that we
talked earlier about even those nitpicky
things like it's really easy to go oh
that that doesn't matter much I can do
it like that or that's not going to be a
big deal but even with him saying hey
should we put the $5,000 aside as you
know our emergency fund even that you
kind of really have to go in there and
go wait a second if I pile all this
money together there's really no
differential between what's an emergency
and what's a month-to-month expense and
before you know it you're going to be
plowing through that quote unquote
savings and so even just making sure
that when you say okay I'm going to
follow this plan that you follow it and
you go okay this is my $1,000 emergency
go over there and then if I have to have
extra cushion in my buget there's you
know $1,000 or whatever that needs to be
in my buget and it is for month-to-month
expenses it's not to go to the mall like
really making Clarity around those
categories in our mind and understanding
that so much of it like you said is is
about how we're framing it in our mind
this money is for this this money is for
that and I stick to my word period yes
so good yeah so money's not a math
problem Jade's quick create it's every
solutions.com but she explain so much of
this in depth and it's so good yeah yeah
all right up next we got luri in
Nashville Tennessee hey lri welcome to
the show Hi how are you we're doing
great how can we
help um yeah so I have $9,000 in student
debt um it's my only debt that I have I
have my car paid off and everything good
for you um I was recently unemployed but
I just got a job so I'm thinking more
about how I can pay off that debt um I
have money in index funds and ETFs um I
only have about 5,000 in there so I'm
just wondering if I should start paying
down my student debt with that money or
if I should leave some of that in there
um just as a little cushion because I
don't have much more savings than what's
in there okay um so yeah well good for
you that's great uh yes I think these
are great options to go ahead and cash
out if it's non-retirement then cash out
everything to throw at the debt which is
which is huge because that'll get you
down to $4,000 left but I do want to
make sure you have at least a$1 th000
emergency fund and you can put that in a
money market account or a high yield
savings and just kind of set that aside
so if that's money that has to come out
of one of these funds I would do that so
cash these out take $1,000 put it aside
and then throw the remaining at the debt
because you have any extra savings at
all
Lori um I am going to get my first
paycheck soon so I think I'll have some
left over in that so I think maybe I'll
be able to build it pretty quickly if I
don't spend a lot anywhere else yeah
that's great yeah so um I would
definitely yeah definitely go ahead and
just casat those out and again make sure
double check on taxes with any capital
gains or any growth that you have um
from those but um yeah use that to pay
off debt which is just it's amazing
that's such a gift that you that you've
done that and then use that same those
same savings goals and kind of muscles
that you have after you pay off that
debt to save up a fully funded emergency
fund and then go on to retirement
investing and on forth and then you know
Vanguard and index funds and all that
can come back in the picture later on
but for now I would use it to get out of
debt well done Lori this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with my
good friend and Ramsey personality Jade
warshaw we're taking your calls it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
8825 5225 up next we have Kevin in Los
Angeles Hey Kevin welcome to the show
Howdy thank you for taking my call so
I'm kind of calling out of desperation
not for myself but uh for my parents
they just pretty much had their whole
world turned upside down the past week
oh what happened so my dad he's a owner
operator he drives a truck and a semi a
CDL and so last week he was stepping out
of his truck and took a wrong step fell
down the concrete got hurt real bad um
kind of try to tough it out and instead
of going to the hospital he went home
instead and when he was home he was
dealing with pain and so he took a a
painkiller thinking that would help uh
and then inside they called insurance
company see if you can get some type of
workman's comp or whatever and uh they
decided to do a your analysis on my dad
which he would end up popping positive
for painkillers oh and and this was last
week had no idea this was happening went
back to work and on Sunday I believe he
was in an accident it wasn't his fault
someone else ran in front of him and his
semi and uh they to away his truck and
as he's trying to figure out how to get
back home to Dallas where my parents
live the accident happen in Oklahoma he
gets a call from the company he leases
on to find out that he is no longer
allowed to drive because he felt his
drug test and they fired him from the
business and so in the matter of a whole
week my dad lost his entire career and
he's in debt they have no emergency fund
they're behind on the mortgage they've
been living on credit and my sisters and
I do not know how to help our parents
out wow wow wow oh I'm so
sorry that's it's like the worst chain
reaction that could happen happens right
and there's no way for him to dispute
any of this I mean
there's you just have to like take it as
is I mean there's no yeah I mean and
it's the worst cuz if you were to know
my father my dad's never done drugs in
his life doesn't even drink alcohol none
of that legit the man was in pain just
trying to go back to work and my sisters
and I didn't realize why he was trying
to go to work so bad until it came he
came out clean saying hey I've been
living off of credit like I have to be
out on the road making money because I
got all this debt I got to pay off I do
have one question and this is may be
neither here nor there but did he have a
prescription that he can say like hey I
I was given this yeah he and it's just
it's it's an expired uh prescription but
yeah he broke his back a couple years
ago and that's where it came from shoot
and we've all done that that's crazy
gosh Kevin okay so you're wanting to
know how to best help your parents we're
we're actually we're having a family
meeting tonight and you know my sisters
and my family they're all in Dallas I
live in California and we're just we're
just trying to figure out like what do
we do
you know like how do we keep our parents
afloat yeah through this whole process
and I one thing I didn't realize which
my sister told me earlier today is like
they're even behind on their mortgage
and no one had any idea man okay where
are you guys at financially Kevin you
and your sisters and like how is
everybody we're I mean we're we're all
okay right um my wife and I we do okay
we both work full time and we have a
little bit extra um you know we've
talked about possibly supporting them my
sister the same way you know I mean we
do we don't have a ton extra but we do
have a little bit kind of so like you
know we want to help our parents the
same time you know like what do we do
yeah my my kneejerk I would love to Jade
I would love to know your thoughts on
this so my knee-jerk reaction is first
and foremost Kevin you have to take care
of your family your wife your kids same
with your sister right I mean that that
that's your priority above all else so I
never want someone to get in a financial
situation where their own family is
suffering because of parents or extended
family right um but if you got I mean I
there's a part of me that would say yes
I think if you guys have the means to at
least be able to help the mortgage side
of it and let them not fall further
behind um and again it's not putting
yourselves in a situ in a dangerous
situation financially but if you guys
are able to help float that um you know
I would totally be okay with that but I
do in Long Term though Kevin this isn't
gonna you're not going to be able to fix
your parents right there's long term
they're gonna have to be the ones that
say we did this our habits are terrible
when it comes to money we have to handle
our money completely differently to get
different outcomes all of that like no
there's nothing in your power and your
sister's power to help save them long
term I'm thinking about the short term
like with like you know December 15th
coming up you know like if like for them
to be able to keep their house um what
are things that you guys could do and I
would be comfortable a gift not to loan
but to say hey here's a set amount of
money that you and your wife Kevin feel
comfortable with if your sister wants to
have that same conversation with her
family and I would probably put a set
amount of money and just say this is
what we have and pile it together and
say this will help them you know for
three months uh catch up to the mortgage
maybe even that like if there's anything
in that vein I would be very comfortable
with you guys doing that if you and your
wife agree on that but um but as far as
a long-term play I mean he's obviously
going to have to find a different job uh
hopefully in the same industry I mean I
guess it's on your record I mean I I
don't know how that how much that kind
of thing follows you yeah there's like a
rehabilitation process but still it's a
process and it takes time right Y how
much time do you know uh it could take
anywhere from like a month to three
months um which is fine but the issue is
like they have no emergency fund it's
like how are they supposed to get
through yeah he's going to have to do
something I me he'll have to drive Uber
or like you know have in your mind
probably your mom's GNA have to step up
and do something as well they don't have
any kids at home right you guys are all
grown yeah how old are they we're all
grown how old are they mom D 62 okay
yeah they can yeah they're going to have
to both just I mean whether they're
putting together side hustles or
whatever it is I mean they're going to
have to have some level of income coming
in to eat um and and it's just and Kevin
I I think too like it's it is a hard
reality when you become the grown child
looking at your parents and thinking oh
my gosh like I'm now switching roles and
I'm having to take care of right and
people find that physically having to
take care of parents financially emotion
I mean like all of this right and so I
do think that there's um some boundaries
there and you know you want to be you
want to do this well but um but yeah as
far as them yeah like you said they have
no savings they have nothing so they
have to a reality check is going to have
to hit them which I'm sure it has where
they're like wow we're going to have to
do things we never thought we're going
have to do in order to order but what do
you feel Jade about about him and his
sister helping catch up to the mortgage
if they have the margin themselves what
do you think look I think that in I
think that I ideally that's what you
want to do I think the hardest part in
all of this I think there's two really
difficult Parts if you're the
spouse being on board with that and
going okay we're I mean because we're
talking about thousands of dollars yes
yes um and knowing that this has got to
be a gift it can't I mean we talked
about this last segment it's got to be a
gift it can't be hey borrow this money
from us and when you get back on your
feet you'll give it back if you guys
agree to do this it's got to be a gift
because especially in the in the
situation that your parents are in they
can't give this money back they don't
have it and you don't want that hanging
over you Kevin and so the spouse is
being on board I I see two dynamics that
have the ability to be kind of funky but
I think you can navigate this a the
spouse B you've got siblings and so
there might be this feeling of like well
we're giving this what are you guys
giving and
just that Dynamic of is it fair who's
giving more I feel like you guys could
have done more like I think you guys are
really going to have to put on your and
it sounds like you do like it sounds
like you're all adults here but keeping
on that truly like big boy and big girl
hat of we're coming to to the rescue
here um and then I think there's another
part of this that's got to be really
firm and especially in the siblings
minds of it's really easy to focus on
this and go what happened to my parents
is my dad fell out of the truck and then
he you know took a pain and like tell
that whole story to yourself but really
what the story is over the course of
their entire lives our parents have not
handled their money well and you've
honestly got to focus on that being the
story otherwise the other story you feel
the guilt of having to oh we got to care
for it I mean my dad just fell and and
so really being able to reconcile that
in your mind is going to be really
important going forward because this is
not going to be a short-term situation
right yeah Kevin hold on the line I'm
going to give you a membership a
Financial Peace University and every
dollar premium to give to your parents
as a gift from us to at least get them
some basic knowledge of how to handle
money and they're 62 and change is hard
for anyone but especially those 60 and
70 year olds it's changing Decades of it
but hold on the line Kelly's going to
pick up and we're going to gift that to
them I'm so sorry Kevin thanks for
[Music]
calling Hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the ramsy show uh so
Jade and I were talking about Christmas
and I guess was it you were on a webinar
what was it that happened and you
thought oh my gosh well it's you know
it's that time of year so it's the media
hits and we've done a couple they've
been like hey can you write a couple of
articles on this I'm like yes and I keep
going back to the same thoughts so the
idea is it's Christmas time right and so
many of you listening and we've all been
there where it's like I've got bigger
fish to fry this year right whether it's
paying off debt or you've got real
savings goals that you're trying to hit
or whatever it is financially that is
very important to you as a priority
sometimes Christmas can really throw you
off of your goals um and specifically
when it comes to getting out of debt it
can really be just that thing that's
like H it's a damper right because it's
like you want to participate in that
traditional way where you're giving
gifts and you're doing all the things
but the reality is if you want to stay
on track and you want to hit your goals
and you want to be responsible you can't
always do all of that and so what does
that look like does it mean that
Christmas is cancelled and we're never
going to get you know it's like you can
really go into that mopy side of it but
I just over the years and for those of
you listening who do know my story you
know like when you're paying off debt
it's tough and for those of you who
don't know the story like when Sam and I
were paying off you know $400 and
$460,000 of debt you have to embrace
Rachel a whole new set of values and
truths when it comes to the holiday
season if you want to get out of it
unscathed with your peace intact and
with your money and your budget intact
and so like I said I've writing some
budgets about some articles about this
and I just want to share with you yes
and the folks listening some of the
truths that I've embraced and hey poke
holes in it like if you're like Jade
that is so Scrooge or that is so like
unrealistic hey be my guest but I'm just
going to tell you what worked for me um
the first thing on my list is and this
is just to set you guys free so if you
want to be free embrace it you do not
have to buy a gift for someone simply
because they bought a gift for you oh
yes like I would agree with that I used
to be that person that would buy like
I'd go to Target and buy like a couple
of inexpensive things just to have them
on hand so when someone gives you a gift
you can give it to them yeah mhm and I
finally was like you know I in my church
there's a lot of folks that I'm friends
with and there's like a lot of people in
my circle and it was just getting to the
point that I was like I am giving 50
gifts like literally to like yes 50
gifts like and I was like I'm not doing
it anymore I would agree with that one
I'm with you on that one because and I
think it takes away it almost can be in
this if you're in that mindset
constantly sure it probably comes out of
from a good place originally but then it
just becomes a okay you give me this
here this it's like the switcheroo thing
that doesn't you weren't even expecting
it wasn't even a gift like you said that
you bought for that person because you
saw it and you thought you know what I
want to do it's just this general idea
so yes that's a lot of times it's kind
of like honestly it's kind of junky like
it's kind of like it's like another
candle yeah it goes in the candle drawer
yes yes yes yes okay so then this one um
this is what one of the things that Sam
and I embrac in our family draw names
yes we do this draw names please yes
because on my side of them it was I have
three
siblings then two nephews then my mom
and dad then Sam's mom his two sisters
they're 1 two three four five seven kids
like a there's a lot yes so my thing is
like okay draw names kids get them gifts
but for the adults like in your family
your nuclear and partially extended
family draw names yes and can I tell you
everyone wants to do that too they want
to they're like oh no really look some
people you know some people Christmas is
a sport for them and they're like yeah
they want to buy gifts for everybody and
it's not that they're mad at you but in
some way they kind of feel like it's
ruining Christmas for them for there not
to be a zillion gifts from everybody oh
that's funny do you know what I mean see
when we talked about it all as adult
siblings this was years go cuz we've
done this for probably 10 plus years I
remember someone had that that said that
and it was separate conversations on
both sides Winston's side and and our
side and all of us were like thank you
cuz for me honestly I'm just like I it's
it's the amount of time the E everything
and I'm like everyone's already
stretched then and especially when you
have kids and all of it so we found it's
great so we did we do a dollar amount
and we say here's the budget for it love
it that everyone feels good about and
then you know what we stopped doing on
Winston side of the family we stopped
telling like oh send me what you want
like text me something yes we stop that
so then your creativity has to kick in
so the thoughtfulness is in that because
you have to think through like they
haven't asked for this yes I'm not
clicking a link that they sent me I am
I'm I have to figure out something for
them and it's great I love that I'm
going to add that to the list because it
also pulls back expectations because
it's very different if someone has said
um and by the way I want bu bu bu and
you're in your mind like calculating the
cost of that and you're like crap that's
not what I plan on spending then you
automatically feel an obligation to get
them that whereas if it's just literally
adults being adults that's right then
that doesn't exist which brings me to my
next point you don't have to buy gifts
for
adults they're grown they have their own
money their own job if they want a new
blender they can go buy it they do not
need you to go buy them slippers like
they can buy their own slippers Rachel
and that's the thing are you saying from
parents to adult kids what what are you
saying cuz Sharon Ramsey this year y'all
Sharon Ramsey was like I don't think I
really want to do Chris I I y'all don't
you sound like Sharon y'all don't need
anything y'all are adult you don't need
anything and my sweet mother-in-law is
like here's your budget every year so
she so we still get kiss from Winston's
parents I don't think we get any from
the ramies this year I really don't but
here's the thing are you mad like are
you like oh my gosh well they're right
now and I'm like well have fun across
the continent we'll see y'all on the
25th evening no no we're not mad we're
not mad it it's
uh it's just funny like I'm a little
there may have been no there may have
been a gift I will the person shall not
be named texted to my mom and she texted
back yeah I'm not sure we're going to be
buying gifts this year but thank you wow
I love it that person will not be named
I am here for that look if you're trying
to get out of debt now especially yes
yeah if you're getting out of debt and
if you're getting out of debt and there
is an adult in your life who is mad that
you didn't get them a
gift okay but what if you're living like
no one else so later you can live and
give then it could be a little a little
questionable that's questionable oh
that's so good I love it all right again
this is for folks getting out of debt or
have extreme goals that they're trying
to hit um here's the other thing that
I've embraced okay if you don't live by
me like in my city yeah to where I can
put the gift in your hand I am not
sending out a gift to you you're off the
list you're off my list yes because I'm
like we're not even we don't even live
by each other just like family friends
what are you thinking yeah I'm thinking
like friends that live far off your
great aunt that you haven't seen she
lives in New York you know that kind of
thing I'm with you I'm with you on that
you're off the list like you're not
seeing them on a day-to-day send them a
Christmas card look at Kelly's face
Kelly May disagree with what do you
think girl we're getting out of debt
Kelly she doesn't have a mic that can
talk for good reason yeah she proba
don't cuss me out back there I can read
your lips I don't think I I don't know
if I have ever ever is an extreme
statement but genuinely I don't think
I've ever gotten like a package
delivered to my door and I open it and
there's like a Christmas get in there
that's never I don't think that's never
happened maybe because we all have
family in town they closer is that has
that happened to you is that what you're
thinking like you go wrap a gift and
then you fed exit to well all of my
siblings except now that I've moved but
most of my siblings live out of state
and it's like I'm like y'all don't have
to send me a gift from California here
like yes yes I'm like I don't know I'm
like if you're in debt I'm grown like I
said I can buy my own Bed Bath and
Beyond you know what I'm saying so okay
that's the next one babies okay do not
need
gifts babies don't need gifts let me
tell you what I did actually they have
no clue that is kind of true can
literally take a gift Rachel and rewrap
it they don't know they think oh this is
great I can just pull the paper off they
play with the paper Rachel what age is
baby to you three three and up three and
younger I think two I think two is the
cut off for being able to do that I will
say when you have one baby and they're
18 months old they have no clue that is
that's that is fair like my daughter is
three and a half I could not do that
with her like she know yeah we're out of
the woods there yeah I think like the
end of two like getting up to two is
like where where you'd have to cut that
off yes all right so babies don't need
gifts what I would do I would focus on
like the children in your life that are
ages 3 to 18 that's that's where that's
the guilt trip you don't want to go on
like you need to get those folks gifts
that's how we end it that's where you
want to be generous it's the
truth man Jade I would have loved to
look at like a list of all the people in
Jade's life that could have gotten a
gift and then just scratch them off one
by one till it's like five people make
it feel good so great oh well thank you
Jade for goinging this hour thanks to
everyone in the booth for making this
happen thank you America for listening
remember to take control of your money
and create a life you
[Music]
[Applause]
love
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with my good friend and Ramsey
personality Jay warshaw and we are here
to answer your questions about life
money relationships career anything and
everything so give us a call it's a free
call anywhere in the country at
5225 up next we have or up first I
should say we have Kristen in Houston
Texas hey Kristen welcome to the show
hey thank you very much for taking my
call absolutely how can we help well my
husband and I are in in financial
transition so we've been paying off our
credit card debt for like the last years
we've been chasing our tail with it
we're due to pay off our credit card
debt by the end of December maybe the
beginning of January okay coming out
great yeah yeah super excited this has
been thank you it's been crazy yeah okay
so our next phase that we want to do is
work on building our savings for down
payment and closing cost to purchase
real estate within the next year or two
this year we made two big decisions well
actually we made two big purchases and
one big decision we we're renters right
now and um our rent was going up and my
husband and I decided okay let's go
ahead and move into an RV well I already
had one that was paid off I traded that
in and we Pur just one and so that's
what we're doing right now is we we have
a brand new RV and we pay space rent so
that's our housing then uh my truck
which was his truck is paid off my truck
is paid off but my truck ended up
meeting like $155,000 of Maintenance and
repairs in the last year and a half just
turn right around have another $1,500
repair and we said forget that we need
to upgrade truck for the RV anyway and
so we went ahead and made uh a purchase
for a a truck to pull the RV how much
did you spend uh 5 we owe
56623 on it right now 56,000 hold hold
did you say you bought a truck for
56,000 yes it's a
2021 uh F250 diesel for
58,000 I'm
shook it was a deal it was a great deal
but our monthly note is nuts um we've
already done that with our budget and
all so and Kristen I'm gonna just ask
the Assumption it's on
payments yeah yeah the payment the
payment is uh 9.46 and some change and
we had to yeah it's nuts wa no wait hold
on hold on hold on I got to call you out
slightly it's the Christmas season so
I'm going to be a little bit
light-hearted first you said it was a
great deal then you just now turned
around and said it's nuts and just for
the record the payment yeah it is nuts
it is y'all just are about to pay off
all this credit card debt you had two
paid for trucks I'm just spelling this
out for you okay well here's here's the
thing is uh we we we thought about this
we went through the budget we uh we did
the budget on the net income not gross
and how we could afford all of that and
so we have it all in the budget and uh
everything together with the truck the
RV and the space rent we're at about
$2,100 okay the his truck is a 2012 my
truck used was a 2011 and high mileage
on both of them we cannot pull the RV
with um either one of his or mine the
differen is and the hard part that
you're going to realize is everything
that you have that money tied up in is
going down in value and I understand
that what you really want is real estate
but I don't think you guys went about
the right way to get there probably not
but given our situation at the time
that's where we were at okay how much
how much can you let's just um real
quick Kristen how much how much could
you sell the truck for
today uh the 21 or the 2011 21 the
$56,000 it would have to be 566 okay so
right around there how much could you
sell the r how much did you sell the RV
for uh right now it's sitting at 43 so
payoff would probably be around 44 45
okay so you do realize your truck costs
more than where you guys live right okay
so there's just parts of this formula
Chris and I need you to see is not the
wisest choice and I need you to say wow
we should not have we should not have
done this because renting is not
throwing your money away what you guys
did is you chose to take on more debt by
getting an RV and then you chose to have
to go deeper into debt to be able to
move the RV so you just dug yourself
into a deeper hole thinking you know it
was the wisest smartest thing to do at
that point but mathematically
financially it just wasn't it wasn't and
so for you guys you guys have have
stepped backwards a lot in this process
so I almost would say like I would I
want everything to be wiped clean you
guys had such a great track ride with
the credit cards like you were paying
down debt paying down debt no no no let
me let me tell you right now that when
we were renting he was making lower
income at the time and we were actually
in more debt over our then you could
have gone to a cheaper rent you could
have no we couldn't we were at hold no
wait a sec wait a sec wait a sec let me
draw it back we can't help you if you
don't want help and here's the here's
what I want to here's what I want to
make clear Rachel and I are going to
look at this and we're going to go hey
this is not the smartest choice we want
you to be free and we want you to be out
of debt now here's the difference cuz I
I agree with you in the way that renting
it doesn't feel good it feels like we're
throwing money down a you know down a
black hole no I could care less about
Renning that doesn't bother me I'm a
real estate broker I understand okay but
what you're not understanding what
you're not understanding here is it
would have been better for you to rent
because rent is not debt and you're just
looking at the payment per month but
you're not looking at the grand scheme
of it okay payment per month doesn't
matter it matters does that make sense
you're looking like oh $2,100 it's less
but I'm like yeah but you're forgetting
about the 56,000 the 43,000 and the land
is more than what we were paying how
about this Kristen what you um for you
calling in what was what was the main
question my main question was you okay
it's not changing what we're doing I
understand you know your philosophy and
everything like that and I understand
what we've done and there's reasons why
we did it okay um and and I understand I
I totally agree with you normal
circumstances sure where we're at right
now okay we'll be freeing up about
$33,000 worth of money every month once
we pay off these credit cards which is
about to be done at the end of the month
in the beginning of next month maybe
okay we have $1,000 in savings every
month okay and we have one month's
reserves for bills all of them okay okay
okay how would you best advise to put
that
$3,000 to our debt yeah how much are you
guys making a year Kristen uh in a year
his gross for this year is going to end
up being year to dat it's it's 1221 121
okay probably be about 1:30 um by by the
end of the month and do you add anything
to that as well no not right now okay I
will but so what I would broker St for a
so what I would do Kristen if you guys
choose we just say not to have I know
things in Motors and wheels that is more
than half of your annual income so so if
it were me Kristen I would be selling
these two things the truck and the RV
like I said earlier I'd go rent
somewhere free up this money save up a
good down payment for you guys to get a
primary home for you and your husband
after 3 to 6 months of expenses I'd put
that in a money market account if you
don't want to do that then the next move
is you have to start paying off this RV
which is
$43,000 and then you need to pay off the
truck before you ever think about real
estates this is the ramc
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netw weite
gave us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it's scaled with us netw
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com SL
Ramsey
[Music]
so Jay kind of wanted just to Circle
back that's I feel like a phrase we all
said during Co I'll Circle back Circle
back um to that last caller Kristen and
and you know I think
what's what can be so hard is we can
ourselves talk ourselves into something
and into situations yeah and be so
clouded by maybe our own judgment our
own ways of thinking that we keep
digging ourselves deeper into a hole and
you're thinking you're on the outside
yelling down and no come out this way
come out this way and I feel like that's
what we were trying to do with her is
just to show and understand it's just
the numbers there's parts of this that
you just go back to just facts and and
$900 a month car payment and and
everything so yeah I mean look
I I am the first one to say when I hear
that kind of talk there's not much we
can do because you've already kind of
painted yourself into this corner of my
ex my situation is the exception and all
of us can find somewhere where we can
say that but you've honestly got a
commit to going okay I've got to just
not make these excuses because all of us
can say well the way my income is set up
or well because we were paying this in
rent or well because all of us can do
that and whenever you do that you
automatically exclude yourself from the
solution you automatically ostracize
yourself from why a plan can't work for
you you just you create you're the
exception and if you want to take on
that identity then that's the identity
you have and nothing nothing we say is
going to be able to help you and I
always hate when that happens because I
am a firm believer Rachel of the idea
that whatever you look for you find it
so if you're always looking for the
reasons that you can't do it then you
never will but the moment you just say
okay I'm going to open up my heart I'm
going to open up my mind a little bit
process and just say I'm going to try
this plan I'm going to try something
different yeah because look and I don't
say this to be anything but real when I
first heard your dad talk he's brass
like he's strong like he comes across
and I remember thinking he's got more
money than I do he's he's figured it out
he's not living paycheck to paycheck
he's not in debt I
am so I'm going just leave leave it at
that I'm just leave it at that because
at the end of the day it's like that's
where you have like that's the way you
have to see it as okay like I'm still
trying to figure this out I haven't
figured it out yet right right someone
who has gotten a handle on it is telling
me hey here's what I did and if you're
not going to take advice from a person
who's done it then you're always going
to be kind of like trying to fight your
way out of a paper bag Y and like you
said the light somebody's shining the
light going it's this way it's this way
yes it's your chice yep absolutely so
good all right let's go to uh Heather
they're in Illinois hey Heather welcome
to the
show hey guys how are you doing great
how can we help hey um I'm actually like
really excited I got on oh so I'm so
glad you're
here so my husband and I are in baby
step number two
uh trying to get rid of our debt we have
um about
$62,000 in Consumer Debt um and we bring
in um like
$6,200 a month after taxes and insurance
and all that stuff um so uh we'd use
every dollar budget the premium to map
out our paychecks and um I was raised in
a church so I was always taught that you
give 10% of your uh take-home pay back
to church like to the Lord because it's
his anyway he's just giving it to us to
manage um so in doing that I typically
budget about $600 a month um in
tithing and after our expenses are paid
for the month we have about $150 extra
to put towards our debt repayment and
we're pretty on fire to try to get rid
of this debt um so
my husband got a work truck that he we
don't have to pay for anything of it he
gets to drive it wherever he wants
that's awesome um so we actually sold my
nice car and I Drive His Old 2005
four-door truck nice because it's paid
for yeah um so we are just trying to get
after this and my question is do I can
continue to give the 10% um to
church I at this moment or do I cut it
down to 5% or just pause it to take the
extra $600 to get rid of put towards our
debt each month um I'm just kind of at
an impact like I kind of feel guilty
doing that but I don't know what else to
do yeah it's a yeah I think it's a I
think it's a fair question for sure and
what's funny Heather is uh we get I get
hate on my the Rachel Cru show for
certain things and recently it's been
this it's been giving people have not
been happy with the fact that I am
pretty set in my ways when it comes to
the giving part because yep so Heather
what I would say okay so there's kind of
two ways I look at giving one is from
more of a spiritual aspect if you're
someone of faith and then people that
are not there's still a factor here so
so for me giving in general regardless
of where you stand spiritually it it is
a practice of character for me there is
something about the continuation of
giving and living with an open hand is a
practice that I want ingrained in me so
deeply regardless of where I am
financially because I am a big believer
that as that becomes a habit and then
you guys start winning people think well
if I just had more money I I would give
and it would be easier and the truth is
that's not necessarily the case
sometimes when you get more money it's
almost harder the yeah it's the easier
not to give the opposite way which
sounds so backwards but it's just crazy
how our minds work and I always want
money to be in a healthy position in my
life and so have it far out with an open
hand um that that's always my stance and
then if you are a person of Faith which
you said you are you know I never want
any part of my faith walk to be
legalistic legalistic stuff just it it
it grosses me I hate it I don't like it
when people are like you have to do this
and this and this you have to do read
the Bible this often like anything like
that rules I'm like nope I I that's not
my thing yeah you go the opposite
direction yeah I'm not a legalistic
person so I don't want your giving from
the spiritual lens to be out of legalism
because that defeats I think the whole
purpose of it I think there's so much in
scripture about being a cheerful giver
and the why and the participation that
we get to participate in something
bigger of what God is doing and I'm not
a Prosperity person either I do not
think that if you give you will be given
back monetarily always I think sometimes
God blesses us but I don't think it's a
a equal C thing there but what I do see
though Heather and I can say this with
confidence
people that give and I would say even
people with faith if you put that layer
on top of it there is a a sense of of of
Joy there's a sense of peace there's
something in there because it is bigger
than just the paycheck that's hitting
your accounts the gifts that you're
giving the consistency of giving and
giving back to the local church which is
the tithe there is something there that
I am choosing to participate and what
God is already doing and so for me it's
it's yes the obedient Factor but there's
also so the The Joy the contentment
learning to live with what you have that
principle is kind of forced in there
especially on a tight budget like you
guys are like there's just so many of
these character benefits that come out
of giving that I can't in good conscious
just say don't do it now I understand it
is tight and some people choose Heather
and I think you're a big girl and you
get to get off this phone call and you
guys get to decide some people choose to
lower you know they do certain
percentages but I I do stick to that 10%
because I think I think the challenge of
it is healthy and I think the Habit that
it causes in
US is just I just see so many positives
and yes it may take longer to get out of
debt mathematically but I think it
forces something in all of us uh that I
think we just need as Humanity look I
I'm with Rachel you know and I can speak
to you Heather too because I you know
getting out of debt that you guys yeah
the long journey of it it is the biggest
Temptation like and I'm going to speak
to it through that lens since you said
you're a CR follower I'm a CR follower
so we'll speak to it through that lens
but it is a Temptation like that's the
first thing you go well nothing's going
to happen like nothing's going to happen
it's not like they're going to cut my
lights off if I stop paying my tithe
right and so but I do think for us like
for Sam and it was an opportunity to
really test God the way he says to he's
like test me in this and see if I'm not
going to throw open the floodgates and
pour out a blessing that you won't have
room enough to receive and like Rachel
said you don't know that it's going to
be money but it will be a blessing even
if it's just the intentionality in your
heart to keep going like he's going to
hold up his end of this thing and when
you build his kingdom he builds into you
and it's not like it's a quidd pro quo
but it's something you get to
participate in and when you do that the
scripture does say that he does overflow
that blessing
so we're saying stick with it Heather
stick with it all the way around such a
great question though thanks for the
call
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
default Ed private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom ref financing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
today's question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
when was the last time you thought about
your dryer vent clog dryer vents are a
cause of thousands of house fires every
year so let the experts at dryer vent
wizard clean yours visit neighborly
domcom Ramsey to schedule service today
wow today's question comes from Brook in
Kentucky she says my husband listens to
you every day so it would be amazing if
you would set one of us straight here we
go we got into debt when we were in our
early 20s we found the baby steps and
haven't looked back our home is almost
paid off with no other debt kids have
enough money in their college funds and
we put 15% of our pay into retirement
I've always been a stay-at-home mom
homeschool the kids and work full-time
from home way to go here's the problem
when we go on vacation I want to stay in
a nice hotel and a fancy room I work
very hard and am not happy unless this
happens my husband doesn't get it at all
he says we just sleep there why spend
the extra money financially the extra
cost is in the budget I don't spend any
money on myself it's the one thing I
want to splurge on I want my husband to
recognize my hard work and show his
appre appreciation by getting the nice
room who's right if it's me what can I
say to make him really understand stand
oh oh my gosh number one Brooke you're
right yes you are right oh man you're
right always always Splurge for here's
the deal with a vacation if you go back
to a place you hate it just takes away
from the vacation maybe I'm girl mathing
this but when you go to a place that you
love it CH I'm like I would cut on food
before I'd cut on hotel for me
personally yeah a nice hotel or a nicer
Hotel all day oh all day look
and Rachel look I'm just listen Jade and
I have stayed in some really bad hotels
in our in our days yeah don't do it I'm
not risking finding a hair in my bed I
am not risking you know the way the sink
looks when it's old and crust like I
just yep it's not worth it it's not a
vacation and especially if you have the
money yeah okay so Brooke here's the
thing I want my husband to recognize my
hard work and shows appreciation by
getting all of this this is y'all's
money to get together so like him
deciding all of it I'm like no you you
get an exact say in it and sure I want
him to appreciate you and your hard work
regardless of vacations and hotel rooms
that's really it um that was kind of the
weird that was the only weird Str he
gets to he gets to decide this and all
of it I don't like that that was the
only weird part about this whole thing
is I don't I don't know that I view the
vacation like when when Sam and I go on
vacation I'm not viewing it as this is
your chance to appreciate me right I'm
thinking of like okay like this is our
family's chance to get away yes and in
my opinion the whole point of staying in
a hotel is to be somewhere a little more
luxurious than where you are right right
right and don't get me wrong everybody's
budget is different but yes I I mean
once she said it's in the budget I'm
like give me the green light it's the
green light all day I know hope Brook
we're on your team and I think your
husband appreci apprting you or you
wanting to feel more appreciated
whatever that looks like is a
conversation outside of the vacation
conversation but try and you could try
and find a way to relate to him like if
whatever he's into that he would be
willing to spend money on kind of try to
find a way to parallel it like if he's
into I don't know like golf just say hey
like you wouldn't want me to go buy you
a I don't what is it a nine iron like I
don't know like try to find a way to
relate it be like you don't want me to
buy you a nine iron from Walmart so
don't yeah don't don't try to buy me a
you know and just kind of relate it to
something he understands and he sees the
value in and maybe that'll help that's
good that's real good oh man yeah you
know something I know the value of Jade
what our friend George camel's new book
Georgie boy he's got a book right now
you guys on pre-sale called Breaking
Free from broke so make sure to check it
out he exposes some of the most common
money myths and excuses out there like
investing traps and mortgage myths and
credit card schemes all of that so make
sure to Ramsey solutions.com store and
pre-order that book it comes out in
January and you get close to $100 of
free items if you pre-order today so
make sure to check that out and also
Jade's quick read that is in the store
as well money's not a math problem
that's in there too so check that out
Ramy solutions.com
store all right up next we have Delaney
in Washington DC hi Delaney welcome to
the
show hi guys thanks so much for taking
my call you're so welcome how can we
help
so my husband and I are kind of going
through a lot of transitions um in life
and we have recently made some decisions
that I'm not feeling so sure about
anymore so I thought I'd call in okay um
so for some background he's 30 I'm 23 um
we got married last year and we now have
a two-month old baby girl um we live
outside of DC um actually in Northern
Virginia um and I was on maternity leave
for a couple of months um and then have
now dropped my hours to part-time um and
with our annual household income we just
can't afford rent anymore where we
currently are um our lease is up at the
beginning of January and they were going
to increase our rent by quite a bit um
so we were kind of figuring out where we
want to be um my husband is in defense
Contracting and um in a couple of weeks
is going to be going completely remote
um so we kind of have a lot of leeway in
terms of where we want to be um with him
probably still having to make occasional
trips into his office in Maryland but um
not very frequent um I'm from Vermont um
and have lived there up until last year
when we got moved to Northern Virginia
for my husband's work my husband is from
Houston um and so we we kind of found a
place um a little bit further out um
because we do really like the area we're
currently living in um to get a little
bit more house to rent um for cheaper um
but I mean now we're just like crunching
the numbers with what my take home pay
is um since I'm part-time and it's just
it's kind of stressing me out it's still
too much I think um and so we're just
trying to figure out where we want to
move and I don't feel like we have a lot
of time to figure it out um because our
move is currently scheduled for next
weekend oh wow wait so where are you
going so we're GNA be um in still
Northern Virginia but out in leeburg
it's like about an hour and a half away
from here okay and that plan is not
feeling right still right because of the
rent yeah um and another big factor I
think with with finances um and we're
we're currently in baby step too but um
finances and also just it's it's
definitely been a difficult transition
um me being a stay-at-home mom and now
working part-time um and not having any
family close by um we have a few friends
that we've made in the last year and a
half we've lived here but it's been
really challenging um not having family
and so I think that's another thing on
my heart for sure go ahead is it for his
like because he's goingon to be able to
work mostly remote is that what you're
saying yes yeah does does he want to
move
back so he isn't really we haven't found
places in Vermont um the renting Market
is horrible um to be close to my parents
um they've offered to let us move in but
um I mean I would love to but my husband
is definitely not on board with that um
so is okay with making it work um at the
new place out in leeburg um and and he's
also in school full-time right now so um
once he's graduating with his degree um
in like a year and a half two years jobs
will open up quite a bit and hopefully
we be able to increase his salary by
quite a bit so we're still you know it's
just it's budget's going to be tight if
we move there um and then Houston is the
other option it's a lot cheaper uh no
income tax and we'd have his family
close by I've visited Houston many times
um since we started dating and I just
every time I'm there I just can't wait
to leave yeah it's it's an acquired
taste for sure it's just really it's
it's really hard for me to so Delan
we're up against the clock so I hate to
cut you off I hate to cut you off but um
so what I would say is that for on the
financial aspect I think it's going to
be really imperative that you guys find
something that's at least you know 25%
of your take-home pay and I think that's
going to relieve a lot of that feeling
of oh my gosh how much do I have to work
you know and like that Financial stress
but also Delany I'm like this is you and
your husband you guys have to figure out
what do we value what do we want out of
our life in the next season do we want
to be close to family um I mean how much
of this
is you know you guys having to
transition into like a it's a different
life right when you're married with with
a baby it's it's it's a grownup world
now and if you want to stay home
full-time part-time you've got to set
yourself in a situation where you can
actually do that and that there's going
to be some form of sacrifice whether
it's where you live how much you work if
he's in school now or saves it for later
there is going to be a sacrifice that
has to be made you guys have to decide
which one it
[Music]
is
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Jade
warshaw and taking your calls uh just
your friendly reminder you guys as
everyone's doing their Christmas
shopping make sure to go to Ramy
solutions.com
sstore because we have our Cyber Monday
sale all week long this week and it's
everything from every dollar premium for
$49.99 you can get a gift card and even
give that as a gift uh audio books as
low as $7 uh Junior's Adventure
storytime collection for
$14.99 books from myself and Dr John
Zone and Ken Coleman and Dave Ramsey uh
books in there that are yeah as low as
you know $10 sales some $20 so make sure
to check that out at ramsy solutions.com
store as you are doing your Christmas
shopping all right up next we have
Melissa in Minneapolis hey Melissa
welcome to the
show hi thank you guys so much for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help so um my husband's about to file
bankruptcy and to the best of my
knowledge my name will not I don't have
to this is related to a business um line
of credit that when he took it out with
a former business partner he signed a
personal guarantee I don't know that he
was super aware of the implications to
that at the
time um that happened I think back in
like 2018 and then the business shut
down with covid um with an
insurmountable line of credit that at
the point just was not able to be paid
back we've been working for um since
2020 with a lawyer to reach a settlement
and try to you know do the best that we
can to pay some of this back at least to
the bank and they' denied us every time
how much is it to a point now
800,000 oh meliss I'm so sorry would be
it's half would be his half would be the
partner but you know they don't really
they're not looking at it individually
at this point
um and so at this point do you feel
confident that do you feel confident
that work working with the lawyer you
will be able to get them to cut it in
half
basically he's not all the conversations
with the lawyer he's like been like we
had a call yesterday and I'm like is
there any other options and he's like do
you have 800,000 I'm like nope we
certainly don't what's the business
partner doing or the ex- business
partner I guess oh we don't really have
a relationship any longer so I don't
know um and I don't know that they you
know would have either to be honest I'm
not sure we really have no idea so so
are they on the line for this or just
your
husband no they are too so they've also
been working with a lawyer we just don't
have any like personal relationship
outside of that so okay but the
expectation though is that he has to
come up and I see that they're seeing it
as a whole 800,000 but if there's a
business if there's another person whose
name is on the loan
too that doesn't Factor so they either
like both are filing bankruptcy or they
both have to come up with you know half
um so the partner is going to be Bing
filing bankruptcy as well correct yeah
the best of our knowled you do know that
okay okay and just to clarify is that
what the court is saying that they both
have to take the same course of action
or if the partner files bankruptcy does
your does you and your husband still
have the ability to just pay off the
400,000 if you choose to like on your
own time no if if it if one files
bankruptcy then it would be entire so
then that's where it would be 800 so as
I'm like can we like if we take the
whole thing will they have a little more
pity on us like we we've asked to settle
we've you know offered different lump
sounds we've offered different payment
plans over you know six years or like
can we pay like 200 100,000 of this over
the course of five six years they've and
to and in lack of better terms they've
actually this has been like I said since
2020 they the attorneys are quite young
for the bank and they keep changing so
we've been ghost for like 9 to 10 months
at a time where we're like oh this might
actually just there's a statute um I
guess that we were like well we might
actually hit that and this might just
disappear because they keep dropping the
ball um it's got to be at least a decade
it was six years from what we had heard
um we were about halfway through but
then they they did do a they filed um
last December 31st they filed something
I'm not exactly sure the terminology but
essentially they filed that which gave
us one year but then come this December
31st had they not responded which they
hadn't until last week that would have
been dismissed but then they came back
next week and they were like all right
this is you have till December 8th is is
the balance growing or is it like is it
frozen it there is it there's interest
growing on it but they're not really
pursuing that for some reason they're
more just going
after the lump sum of like kind of when
the business to shut down it it looks
like I mean because the the total on the
last statement I got was over
900,000 but they're asking for like 8817
so what chapter are they gonna put you
guys in do you know well that I'm when
I've read about it I'm thinking seven
yeah um just because of the ability to
pay this back and everything else that
goes along with 13 yeah um it seems like
seven is our option the the stick to
that is like we were just about to pay
off our cost
like we don't have other debts and this
just feels wrong but yet we also just
sign I mean yeah and that and that's a
little bit of that hard reality of and
and my and Dad Dave talks about this a
lot with you know his story of
bankruptcy yeah where I mean like
there's there's a truth that it feels
like the
system it's like man make it half and we
you know I mean like like the system
part of it is frustrating um right but
then at the end of the day this is this
is what happens you know when when you
sign your name to something and it's
heartbreaking and terrible as it is um
yeah it is what happens how is how is he
doing your husband he he's actually I
mean his attitude toward it is much
better than mine I'm like this is pain
and anguish this is Devastation he's
like yeah this really sinks he was like
but we have to just move on like this is
going to happen it's going to be wiped
out he like and we just move on he's
like we're almost on cash anyways yeah
that's what we're was our goal that's
where we want to go so we're almost
there and then our the attorney said
that you basically once we file it stops
the bank from being able to like do
anything to us about this 800,000
garnish wages the next day you can just
move on you know I'm like we just move
on I'm like okay but the I guess the
kind of things that we're not super
clear about or that we being told by the
attorney to do one thing and that I
don't agree with is like our cars we so
we have some loans on our cars but the
way our income works is my husband kind
of makes like large chunks of money at a
time so we'd be able to pay off like we
have about 11,000 on one of his cars
that we were just about to pay off last
month when this kind of came the light
that it's like no don't pay off your
cars because there's we can only keep
like there's like 5200 of equity that's
protected in vehicles and then they can
take the rest like if your car's paid
off yeah you know don't do that they
like okay we're you know but I'm like
we're really close like to paying that
stuff off and now we were told to turn
the cars in and Lease them and lease a
different car instead because then we
don't technically own it but then I'm
thinking in three years then his credit
I'm assuming it'll be trashed and the
lease is up and we'll have sunk a bunch
of money in that we couldn't save and
then what you know I'm like I I don't
know what about your home is it
protected under like the like do you
have the homestead protection to where
they protects our Equity up to 450,000
so I know that with what we owe on our
mortgage all our house is worth um
that's been pretty clear that our house
is safe okay that was my number one
question yeah so that's all safe um
there's going to be something he said
with this that called like a
reaffirmation of the loans basically
after it's filed because there is going
to be something that happens with the
house even though it's like we've never
missed a payment we're not behind at all
he like just unfortunately that's but
it's assets yeah you do a personal
guarantee it's it's your life there I
mean yeah that is is how lose their
houses and everything yeah yeah my name
is not on this and I guess there are
marital protections which help us as
well because my name wasn't you know I
was not part of the business not any of
it you know so y there's a little bit of
that but yeah so the house is safe um
the cars sound like they're safe but
there's a little like discrepancy and
I'm like it's like well you might just
have to buy your car back for 5,000 on
top of it sounds like you're about to
walk through a really difficult season
and this is a season where you guys are
going to have to hold on to each other
abely I was going to say I mean it it
does not it won't take you out right
people have recovered and have changed
their family Legacy because of this
event like this and that's what we want
to see you guys' story go through
Melissa but it it is it is gutr to the
identity and the core of who you guys
are and so stay with it thank you so
much for calling this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work they
love and create amazing relationships I
am Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with my
good friend and Ramsey personality Jade
warshaw and we are taking your calls
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at
5225 answering your questions on life
money relationships career anything and
everything so first up we have Calvin in
Portland Oregon hey Calvin welcome to
the show hey how you doing we are doing
great how can we
help I just wanted a unbiased opinion on
this I'm uh just made it to baby step
three uh right as I was transitioning
jobs I had left a previous company due
to some disagreements about the way
things should be done and undercutting
management on so forth uh the company I
came to had made some promises and
benefits uh they matched my pay but when
I got here uh they didn't hold up their
end on a lot of things they're doing
some shady stuff they not following
oosha
regulations and we're really kind of
screwing over the residents uh by not
taking care of the units that were
turning
currently I have a potential job offer
with a pretty reputable company who's
offering better
benefits uh a retirement fund a better
schedule things like
that okay how old are you 22 okay and
the first job you left what was the
disagreement over your last job I had I
had been promoted after working there
from service tech to manager after a
year and a half um whenever I got the
management position I was told aside and
told that I'm the youngest in the
company I'm
inexperienced and they're going to be
taking charge of my
property and that was something they
hadn't done to any other manager before
whenever I tried to talk to HR and
things like that try to come to some
kind of solution it got pinned on to me
and eventually my schedule started
getting changed they started threatening
my job and so I ended up putting in my
two
weeks okay can I clar can I ask a
clarifying question um when they pulled
you aside to have these
conversations was it was the reasoning
simply because you were the youngest in
the company and some people didn't like
that or was the reasoning you're the
youngest in the company therefore were
finding like performance issues was was
there any performance issue on it or it
was just like we don't like that you're
doing well at a young age does that make
sense am I missing something no that
that makes sense and that's one of the
things that I'm I was struggling with
understanding and had tried to get
clarification because I had never been
written up um i' had been talked to
probably one or two times you know just
flip UPS yeah uh previously but other
than that I had good reviews from my
residents everyone else was saying I was
doing a good job everything was kept up
yeah and and Calvin what's your line of
work uh Property Maintenance Property
Maintenance okay yeah because I think
the thing about careers and stuff and
and if I was talking to 22-year-old
Rachel I would tell her this um there's
a lot of crappy businesses out there
there's a lot of crappy bosses there's a
lot of stuff that you run into and
you're just thinking oh wow these people
don't keep their word they're doing some
shady things like that is a reality
Calvin that is a reality there's also a
reality too and again I would tell
22-year-old Rachel this that Rachel you
don't know as much as you think you
might you know that there could be
problems within different circumstances
that are racial problems Rachel may
think it's everyone else's problem but
it's really rachal problem and Kevin I'm
not saying you're one or the other but
usually that's what we find especially
if you know when you say you know you
there was a yeah a job you just left
because of questional leadership which
could be very legitimate uh and then you
come to a new job and find out again
just like point a there's crappy people
and crappy businesses and you're
thinking oh gez I picked the wrong one I
need somewhere that's reputable and
great and you're going to thrive and
it's going to be awesome right I I I am
going to give you the benefit of that
out that that is your situation but I
would say also Calvin just to have the
humility always and I still at my age in
this too um that when issues do arise
there are times that it's us that we're
the issue not always everyone else so
just always keeping that in the back of
your head Calvin but if you really are
working for a company that did not hold
up their end of the bargain and did not
do things they said they were going to
do and then even the way they run things
you just don't morally feel good about
that is a valid reason to switch so if
you have another opportunity even if the
even if the opportunity didn't even have
all these great benefits that you laid
out yeah that would still just be a
reason to say I don't feel comfortable
working because if I can't trust them to
not comply with certain regulations I
can't trust them with me right as as an
employee and how they're going to treat
me oh yeah that's right um and then if
for some reason this one doesn't work
out then you do have to do what Rachel
said and be like okay maybe I'm what's
my job process selection looking like am
I going on the Craigslist and looking at
stuff that's you know just like the
wrong option but you know I I'm with
Rachel 100% I do think that I think
you're young going in as much as you can
ask really clear questions going in of
and and really understand what the
expectation is for your benefit anytime
it's like okay when I get here what is
your expectation what does when you say
this is what we expect you to do what do
you mean by that like get as much
clarity as you can so you
know that you're hitting your mark right
and I think that's the best thing that
you can do in this next situation
absolutely up next we have Kevin in
Huntington West Virginia Hey Kevin
welcome to the show hi hello how can we
help um okay I have
I'm not very familiar with your all's um
stuff I I've kind of just started
watching um some of your highlights and
stuff on YouTube recently um but enough
to get an idea a basic idea of like the
de snowball stuff um and I've gotten
myself into a little bit of a bond like
I'm not I'm not drowning yet okay but I
kind of see that if I keep going the way
I'm going I've kind of just been jumping
from crisis the crisis and juggling y
everything and making it work for a
while yeah I kind of see that if I stay
on that path that um I'm gonna be
drowning before too long okay so Kevin
we're up against the clock a little bit
so I want to make sure we get to your um
to your question and situation so um how
much yeah how much debt do you have um I
have uh 63,000 total okay um 40 40 47 of
it is between cars
um 2900 of it is uh credit Consumer Debt
okay um I have 9,000 uh student loans
and uh 3,800 in collections
okay um some of that some of the credit
some of the Consumer Debt is like uh
like Rent A Center kind of stuff like
weekly payments y um and my question is
th those aren't necessarily the
smallest you know Kevin I'm going to
hold I'm going to keep you on hold for a
second we're heading into a break a hard
clock so you'll hold on to the hold on
the line I'm putting you on hold we're
going to come back to you after the
break so that we can really walk through
these numbers especially as a new caller
I want to make sure Jaden and I kind of
get a full picture of your situation and
help you best cuz I think this could be
a turning point for you Kevin I'm
excited so stay on the line we'll be
right back with
[Music]
you
so we held over a call from last
segments and we're going to talk to
Kevin in Huntington West Virginia he's a
newer listener to the show and has
$63,000 in debt everything from Cars
credit cards uh student loans and trying
to figure out you know this feeling that
he's on the cusp of possibly living
crisis to crisis is like he's kind of
right at that edge and possibly wanting
to do some things to change that so
Kevin thanks for holding on the line yep
okay so as we were talking you were
saying some of your consumer debts I
think of the 2900 that was credit cards
is also you were saying was it uh
furniture from Rena Center yeah yeah
like stuff like that like a bed um I had
to buy tires for my truck and I I
finance it weekly pay um kind of stuffff
how much of it is that
uh about
$3,000 okay and what what does that
amount to
monthly um well it's it's weekly pay
okay we each one of those comes out
weekly um the the cheapest one is $21 a
week the other one's $30 a week the
other one's $74 a week can you give it
what happens when you give back the
renter stuff like what happens if you're
like I don't want to rent it
anymore
um nothing they they just get it back so
the payment's the payment you can't go
you can't say I don't want to rent it
and and get out of it no yeah yeah no I
can take it back and I just don't have
that stuff anymore have the tires I
couldn't I would have the payment
anymore okay I would go through and go
what can I give back like obviously you
need tires on your car but is there a
way that we
can save up some quick cash and get you
the tires you need and get cuz I want
you to get out of that as quickly as
possible cuz the interest on I'm sure is
not great no it's not and that that was
my
question because I I've recently got my
a side hustle um I got a job basically
to do nothing I'm on call for a recer
service where if I get a call I have to
go out and work but it's overnight and I
usually don't get called and it's $300 a
week um and I can get out from under
like the one is $26 so I could pay it
off the check and that I'm off from I'm
out from under that one and freeze up
2132 to roll into another thing with the
debt snowball yeah I for me things like
Rena Center that's akin to like payday
loans and stuff it's really just
scraping the bottom of the barrel so I'd
want you to get that stuff clean and
honestly like I said I'd be looking and
going what can I just give back and if
you're making $300 doing this wrecking
service how quickly can you save up what
you need for tires Baseline you know
what I mean and just get yourself back
on your feet in that way and then you've
also got this dead in collections
and so the way you listed it out you
know 47 or $47,000 in cars 29,000 in
credit I want you to go through even
further with a fine Toth comb and really
list each debt in order from smallest to
largest because that's going to give you
not only a clearer picture of truly
what's going on but it's going to break
it down in a way that you can like you
just said hey this one is for you know
$2,000 I can I can tackle that and it's
going to help you see it in its smallest
form so that you know okay like what is
it going to take how many hours do I
need to do okay I can pay that one off
and you're just going one by one line by
line um yeah for the cars Kevin how much
you said 47,000 for cars so how much is
each
car um for my truck it's $700 a month uh
or what like total loan sorry no 22,000
22 for your truck okay and what's the
next car uh my wife's SUV it's 243
24,000 okay and then 2,900 on credit
cards yes that's including the the
rental centers that's right you were
saying that okay y so yeah if you'll
break those out per credit card per
renaer 7 700 on one 300 on another um a
th000 for uh a bed 500 for my tires and
$200 um for a computer okay um then like
if I paid off the computer with the
check that I get today y yep that's
exactly right and and $9,000 in student
loans is that right yes okay and then
some in
collections 3800 what's your income like
you and your wife's combined income uh
combined are take-homes of uh just over
100,000 that's a Tome okay good so
$63,000 in debt 100,000 take home you
know there's a part to this where I go
okay what would happen if you guys lived
on
$60,000 and you're going through this
you've got 40,000 just in your money
that you can put towards this every year
plus 300 a week side Hustle the side
hustle and your wife getting a side
hustle when you look at it like that you
realize Kevin that this can you can
knock this out fairly quickly 18 to 24
months right well that and yeah and like
that was why I called because like the
de snowball it's it's I think it's the
list smallest to largest right that's
right exactly take on the and like some
of these weekly payments aren't smallest
but if I attack the weekly payments
first and got them paid off really quick
that has me paying like $2,500 a week
towards the ne uh uh $2,500 a month
towards the next well the smallest to
largest is not the payment size it's the
size of the debt the total debt oh okay
so you look at like if you like you said
with those renters I think you said one
of the total debts was 200 one of the
total debts was 300 right yeah so those
would be my small I was thinking
payments nope by by the balance by the
balance and you want to stay current on
everything so you'll stay current on all
the payments pay off that smallest and
then Kevin you guys you know you and
your wife because you know I mean even
just this picture of the Deb this isn't
to shame or embarrass you but you know
it's a picture of like this is normal
like you guys were just kind of doing
what you wanted and you make great money
and you're probably feeling like how are
we broke like how do we feel like we
have no money and we have to go to Renta
Center for our furniture when we make a
$100,000 a year combined like this
shouldn't like this is not should be and
so as you guys start this process Kevin
I would really encourage you to lean in
when you start to feel these wins
because I would bet you Kevin that you
make you guys may look up at the $24,000
SUV and be like man could we sell it for
26,000 get 2K and get a crappy car for a
little bit and and knock this out even
sooner cuz there's a taste of Freedom
Kevin that you guys have never had have
never experienced and for you and your
wife doing this process together it is
huge it's huge so I want you to stay on
the line because we want to give you
Financial Peace University for you and
your wife to go through together and you
guys it's our seven it's our nine lesson
course and you guys walk through that
and every dollar premium and this is our
budgeting app that connects to your bank
and it's really going to help you guys
list out very specifically hey here's
our paycheck where is it all going this
is going to give you a road map to get
this stuff paid off and I think yeah
with the side hustle and everything
Kevin this is it I mean yeah your
question was what's the best use of our
months I bet yeah our side hustle money
and it's to yep throw at that smallest
debt amount and as you guys start to
really make this traction and this
progress you're going to feel it and
it's going to be it's going to be
amazing and we're here for you so keep
keep watching the show and listening for
that encouragement because the way
you're going to view money is totally
different than how you've lived and it's
going to feel uncomfortable at times
it's not going to always be fun during
the season of sacrifice but the more you
guys sacrifice and really buckle down
down yeah the traction you're going to
see is amazing look and you you hit the
nail on the head you know $100,000 you
think all right we're we're doing well
like the average family is somewhere
around 67,000 so if you are above that
Mark kind of status tells us hey that's
good you're doing well and it does feel
weird when you're like wait a minute I'm
buying my furniture at Rena Center like
I told I can't buy tires I can't buy
tires and you know I told you during the
break I I I knew this couple they were
older than us but when I was in college
I went to their house and I remember
them saying like our furniture is from
Rena Center and they had two giant SUVs
that were brand new and I remember
thinking wow they've made it but they
their situation was probably very
similar to what we just heard and I've
said this before and I'll say it again
when you start to make these changes it
will show so if you tried to do this in
a vacuum or in the quiet like you have
to just accept hey if I really want to
do this and I want to do it faster I
might drive a different car like people
might see me going from driving a 2023
Infinity down to you know a 2015 Camry
and they may ask me questions about that
and that is okay number one it's none of
their business unless you want it to be
their business but if they ask you
there's no shame in saying you know what
we were out of control and we're getting
our life back y like let's normalize
that as the status symbol of Amen I'm
getting my life back and I am being a
responsible adult and when you give back
that bed to Rena Center and give back
you know the tires to Rena center that
is you being a responsible
[Music]
adult
welcome back to the ramsy show and
standing on the debt free stage we have
Connor and Julian with us welcome you
guys hello thanks for letting us be here
well congratulations we always know when
there's people with headphones on the
debt free stage that there's always a
good story uh where are you guys from so
we are from Oklahoma City okay awesome
and how much debt did you guys pay off
we paid off 288,000
amazing what kind of debt was it so it
consisted of student loans uh rental
property as well as our primary
residence W paid off our house we did
amazing how much were you guys making
during that time uh we started at 74,000
and finished right around 103 okay and
how long did it take you uh 38 months 38
months wow amazing you guys okay so 38
months ago what happened what what
caused this radical change of paying off
almost $800,000 of debt so I got started
on the plan before we got married um we
were still dating at the time and once
we got married we we hit it hard um I
told her kind of the game plan she knew
what she was getting herself into cuz I
was already hardcore on the D Ramsey
plan um and so then from there once we
had a combined income we just hit the
ground running wow okay so what was the
debt I guess we what was the debt
goinging into to the marriage was it who
had the rental property who had the
student loan so I I had the rental
property it was actually a previous
primary residence from my first Duty
station okay so wow so my question is
I'm looking at a rental and a house what
are those properties worth so that was
kind of the key we we that was how we
paid off we sold the rental property to
which was a big part of paying off our
primary residents wow how much was that
how much of that was so we sold the
rental property um we left with about
$100,000 in equity when we sold that
good for you amazing so that added of
course to the 288 absolutely amazing was
that a hard decision to make cuz a lot
of people that call this show they love
a rental property they always want to
keep and especially in the military it's
definitely not the the norm um to not
keep the property um but I had purchased
that property right before kind of
really diving into the Dave Ramsey plan
yes so I knew when we left that that was
the the best decision to make okay and
what branch of the military are you in
uh army army okay thank you thanks for
for your service yeah definitely so what
what caused you to dive into the plan
like how did you get acquainted with
this plan how'd you find it what was
your first reaction so I have always
been pretty uh financially oriented I've
always had an interest in it um but I
think my dad was getting tired of me
asking him questions about finances he
purchased the um Financial Peace
University CD bundle and had it shipped
to my house I I went listen to that
about two times over on my way to work
every day and I just I just bought in
dove in head first so great and how long
have you guys been married we've been
married for just over three years three
years okay so so Julian you knew what
you were obviously getting into he's
very focused you can tell Conor Conor
knows what he wants oh yes uh so what
were you thinking when you when he
brought this up I guess I'm assuming
when y'all were dating even this was a
conversation oh absolutely so I was not
a stranger to Dave Ramsey I my parents
in high school made us do the financial
peace class with our youth group so when
he told me that he really wanted to do
it I said I mean that's fine I'm not the
money person I don't ask me my advice so
I was I was I was ready to do it yeah it
was it wasn't as hard to switch using
like just my debit card to just using
like straight cash it wasn't as hard as
I thought it was going to be because it
made me actually you know like not spend
all my money made me you know budget yes
so you went like full cash mode like
full cash envelopes absolutely I love it
I love Conor is Conor is Hardcore I can
tell um okay so what was the hardest
part because you're newly married right
and I just feel like especially that
stage I like there's different stages of
life like when you graduate college
after you get married there's certain
points in life that it just feels like
everyone around you is living at a
certain right like lifestyle degree of
what they're doing MH so what was hard
about that did you feel like that was
kind of around you and you had to push
back or were you were you so focused
that you didn't feel like there was a
lot of Temptation um no definitely there
was definitely some Temptation um a lot
of a lot of friends didn't really
understand what we were doing they they
didn't appreciate that we couldn't
always do all the things that they were
doing um but for the most part like our
families were all completely on board
like we definitely had a strong a strong
uh cheerleader Squad so I would say all
in all the the the friend group part was
the hardest part of it yes for sure on
the social side absolutely I could yeah
I could definitely see that so what
would you say the key of getting out of
debt is if someone asks someone
listening or watching right now and
they're thinking oh my gosh we we're
Newly Weds we have all this debt and
look at them on stage they're they've
done it what would you say to someone
that things that they have to do to make
this progress this process work so I
I'll say two things one one General and
one military specific I'd say General
this living living onless on what you
make I think we all know and that's a
common thing I know that gets set on
here um but for military specific it's
it's not trying to do what's popular and
what everyone else is doing I think it's
very popular in the military for people
to try to acquire a home at every Duty
station and then people end up with four
or five houses in four or five different
cities and that's where we were for a
second and I was like that's that's not
going to work that's not the best way to
do this and once I saw that we could pay
off our primary residents by selling the
rental property it was hands down easy
decision can I ask about that because
that I could imagine the influence of
that like there's all these people
around you they're doing this thing
was it as simple as going heyy you guys
are doing this it doesn't seem to be
working well for you like how were you
able to reconcile that because it is
hard to look at what everybody seems to
be doing especially if it looks like
it's working and do the exact opposite
talk more about that so for for me it
was a little bit easier because both of
both the houses were on 15year fixed
mortgages um so where a lot of people
have it financed on a 30-year mortgage
and they're like oh well I'm making $200
a month rent to to their mortgage and
and we were never making a profit off of
the rents because we were we had a
higher mortgage at 15 year and so that
also you know we were at a point where I
was like well we're really one bad roof
or HVAC system away from come on a bad
time so that's when I was like this
longdistance landlord is not not for us
we're not going to do that you started
turning on your brain and thinking about
like what this really really means for
your situation I love that so good okay
so how does it feel it's outstanding
I mean it's crazy you guys own your home
how old are you guys uh 28 I'm 25 holy
crap wow wow I mean that's so remarkable
you guys that's un unbelievable so all
the hard work and the sacrifice which I
know part of this was the rental um
house that you sold but but
$180,000 came from you guys living it
out and so if someone asks was it worth
it what would you say ABS
absolutely no question amazing and I'll
just say the one thing on that is is a
lot of people if they saw our story just
from afar they might think oh you know
that's that's an easy way to to pay off
debt but I want people to know that we
got extremely lucky with the covid-19
market on how much our house in El Paso
appreciated yes um so that was a huge
part of and and like I said that was
luck that was not the norm as far as as
buying and selling real estate goes so
abolutely we got lucky in that regard I
don't want to think people to think that
anyone should just buy and sell a house
like that that's a very good point
that's so great oh you guys well Connor
and Julian you're amazing and your and
your late 20s mid 20s and and you guys
have done it and I'm like and now
seriously people called the show in
their 50s and 60s and they're like why
didn't we do this earlier and you guys
get such a head start and so I see you
have some cheerleaders next to you here
on your left who who's with you today so
uh aunt and uncle that live locally here
and then our son Logan so you have a son
Logan oh he's so cute oh my gosh how and
how old is he he is a year and a half
year and a half okay well you guys we
have the live and give bundle for you
guys to enjoy or give away all the
pieces within that because you guys are
definitely living like no one else so we
have Connor and Julian from Oklahoma
City who paid off
$288,000 including their house wow in 36
months making 74 to 108,000 count it
down let's hear your big debt free
scream 3 2 1 we're de
[Music]
[Applause]
free amazing
oh absolutely incredible I am shook I am
shook they're not even 30 well that's it
that's where I'm just like you can
decide you can decide yeah and there's a
and there's a road to be walked down
that but man what an incredible what an
incredible life that they're about to
dive into finan and in so many ways
absolutely amazing congratulations Conor
and Julian this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day comes from 1
Corinthians 1613 through1 14 be on your
guard stand firm in the faith be
courageous be strong do everything in
love Dorothy Bernard said courage is
fear that has said its prayers huh
courage is fear that has said its
prayers there you go I'm going to
marinate on that that's a good quote yes
all all right up next we have Colin in
Fort Worth Texas hey Colin welcome to
the show hi thank you um I'm trying to
figure out what I need to do I am 21
years old I am $42,000 in debt and I
just got laid off two weeks ago and I'm
in a bind kind of thing I am borrowing
money from my aunt and uncle but I don't
have I don't have any payments until
about 3 weeks from now wow um what's
your living situ ation are you renting
are you living with family uh I am
living with my aunt uncle right now um
they are helping me out um but one of
the rules is with me living with them
I'm getting my GED uh I did drop out of
high
school um before I got laid off I was
making a crapload of money for my age my
sister always told me to listen to y'all
she told me to give yall a call to help
me figure it out that's where most of my
debts coming from is from Cars um just
wasn't spending my money WI L how much
were you
making I was making from 1,800 to 2500 a
week
okay okay um and what kind of work were
you doing uh I was an Oiler I worked on
the road I worked in Kansas New Mexico I
maintained heavy equipment so and are
you are you trying to get back into that
same field or are you looking to do
something else um I'm pretty religious
in my life and I don't necessarily what
I've learned over time
money is not worth it to me and actually
I want to become a firefighter I've
always wanted to be one okay I want to
go to school and I want to try to work
on that and I know uh where I'm at in
Texas uh there's a program that pays for
you to become a firefighter but they
only accepted like a thousand people and
it's at the end of September okay so
that's a long ways trying to figure yeah
I'm trying to figure out a way to manage
until then or trying to get out of debt
or figure something El what's the 42,000
uh Colin
what I have a I have a sports car which
is 24,000 of that and then I have a GMC
sier which is the other is a truck and
how much is that it is I think it's like
19,000 or something like that or 18,000
okay so they're it's all cars literally
two cars yes ma'am and then I have two
other cars also what hey how much are
those U I have a Chevy Tahoe it's paid
off it's about 12,000 I would say it's
worth and then I have a Honda Civic but
has a blown up motor right now wow how
much could you pay how much could you
sell it if you just like without a motor
with anything just sell it yeah that's
uh that's what I'm working on I have a
buyer from next week how much how much
will you get for it about 1,800 okay is
what he wants to offer all right um
that's not gonna last me so long Colin
we got to sell up these cars Bud
honestly Colin I would just have a
massive car sale I would sell everything
I would sell them all everything must go
I would sell I would sell all of them
what could you get for the sports car
you owe 24 24,000 how much could you get
for it do you think so the problem with
me I love cars and I'm a car Enthusiast
I have modified it and to a dealership
they're offering 12,000 is what I got
offered for for the 24,000 okay okay not
a dealership did you Kelly Blue Book
it yeah so Kelly Blue Book came back at
16,000 but with the modifications they
said it's going to be less so I'm stuck
with trying to sell it private party
yeah is what I'm stuck with is this
because you did a bunch of stuff to it
yes it makes a lot more horsepower it's
a very fast
car so I put so I've put about $12,000
into it except for buying it also on
top what about the other car what about
the 19,000 yeah um that's the most
reliable vehicle I have I would say how
much did you sell it for
uh I could sell it for around 15 is what
a dealership offered me so if you sold a
Tahoe if you sold the Civic you could
cover whatever you're upside down truly
in either car like even if you chose to
take the hit on the sports car I'd
probably focus on the $19,000 car the
Sierra and I'd get rid of those three
for sure yeah and then you're going to
make
12,000 uh maybe yeah 1,800 from the the
Honda so that's 14,000 that you're going
to make off of selling the other cars so
you can cover some of the difference the
4,000 um with that keep the sports car
and you're going to have 10,000 to put
towards that yeah I mean honestly
without a job right now Colin I just
don't like you sitting with a
$24,000 I don't know if you'll be able
to get a loan for the difference on all
of these either um you know cuz usually
we get we take a loan out for the for
the difference but if he gets the 12K
from the top
then he can cover he honestly could
cover the upside down the 4,000 from the
Sierra and he'd probably be able to
cover the other 5,000 from the sports
car y cuz what are you paying in
payments for the sports car and the
Sierra every month combined I am paying
$450 for the Camaro it's a Camaro and
then uh for my Sierra I pay I think it's
like
$270 I mean look at that that's
$700 that's over $700 a month that
you're getting back
that would insurance I'm paying an
insurance I'm paying about 780 a month
also for cars being, I mean look at that
and then you could take some cash and
you could buy yourself a cash car clear
like you said you're into cars so you
know how to pick a car for $5,000 that's
just going to be your temporary thing
until you get back on your feet and then
you can add money to that and upgrade
but you I mean you got $42,000 of debt
it's all cars and you don't have a
job yeah and the thing about this is
like that house of cards came down but
you get to build back up stronger and
you get to build build back up on the
right footage so it feels bad right now
but it doesn't have to stay that way and
I don't want you to think that we're
like you know trying to take all your
toys away from you and you know put you
in the corner we just want you to get
out of this debt you're living with your
uncle and Aunt who are nice enough to do
that and this is you going look I made a
mistake I'm going to make it right so I
can get up out of y'all's house so I can
stop borrowing money and next time cuz
there is going to be a next time where
you make great money and you're going to
treat it the right way and you're going
to buy things in cash and you're not
going to go into debt because you know
you will have then known how it feels
for that to cave in on you and you're
never going to do that again yeah cuz
Colin you know you said earlier in the
call that you I think he said something
like I'm a religious person so I'm not
money is not everything to me anymore
you know and that's true but money is
something when you don't have it all and
you got two car payments so like there
is a level of having money in its right
position and I think that's what you
were saying which is very Noble that yes
money is not everything but you do have
to have it as a tool in life so you have
to learn to manage it right so you're
either going to choose to manage it well
and wise so that it doesn't become an
idol in your life or if it's the thing
that you're stressed over and over and
over and over and over every single
month living month to month and stress
it's going to become an idol so as
spiritual as we want to make it for it
not to be you actually can choose for it
not to be an idol to have control over
it and I think that's one of the best
things that you can do Colin and I think
that this is a wakeup call I think there
was a part of you that we all have this
like little inner child that kind of
once and once and once I see it when J
crew has a sale or whatever it may be
that you're like this what I want I want
that I want that yours happens to be
cars and I think Colin there's a level
of maturity here that you're like I'm a
man you're getting your GED which I
think is fabulous and you want a career
that you said is a firefighter and it
doesn't you know you said it's not going
to make a lot but that's okay cuz money
is not a big thing to me well guess what
you get an option to be a firefighter
and maybe not make his money
when you don't have debt but you don't
have that option to make that kind of
money solely when you have all these car
payments too so like that's the
trade-off I want you to see that living
without debt not only frees you up
financially and spiritually emotionally
if we talk about but it frees up your
options like if you have no payments
then you can say yeah I'm going to
choose to be a firefighter make less
than what I made in the oil fields but I
literally can't CU I don't have bills so
like I have the freedom to choose that
which is beautiful and that's what
you're starting to see Colin is that it
gives you options like it gives you the
ability to make decisions with your life
you know I was talking calling to this
young couple when I first started
speaking and they had close to $180,000
in student loan debt combined they just
got married out of college they went to
two Christian universities they wanted
to be missionaries whoa and you can't
I'm like I don't know I don't know what
to tell you you have bills to pay so
Colin this is the best thing for you I'm
so excited for you sell these cars
become debt free get a side hustle work
till September to be able to be go be a
firefighter and do what you want to do I
love it Jade thanks for being an awesome
co-host as always thanks to all the guys
in the booth thank you America for
listening remember to take control of
your money and create a life you
[Applause]
[Music]
love
la